foreign
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Peters Morgan on censored tonight
Britain crowns a new King in spine
tingling style has this Festival of
Royal further silence the doubters or
did the silencing of protesters Mar the
celebrations will debate
a British actress Sparks outrage by
slamming the Royal balcony is terribly
white so does the coronation really have
a diversity problem and is our monarchy
terribly white or is that a terrible
opinion what about that too but she's
one of the Republican party's rising
stars in America one of the most
controversial politicians there many
think Karen a could even be Donald
Trump's future running mate tonight she
joins me
[Music]
from the news building in London this is
Piers Morgan uncensored good evening
from London welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored the eyes of the world were on
Britain this weekend 300 million pairs
of them in fact a record and once again
we pulled it off once again we did it in
spine tingling fashion every boot was
shining every Jewel was glistening there
wasn't a foot or a feather out of place
the monarchy is the face that Britain
shows to the world until the thousands
of service men and women the countless
volunteers and the legions of police who
made it safe we salute you for making us
proud the doommongers told us nobody
really cares about the Monarch anymore
they might want to look away
thank you
[Music]
well I was at Buckingham Palace on
Saturday it was absolutely magnificent
they'd be proud to be British if you
didn't make you proud to be British
something wrong with it coronation
weekend was a celebration of what this
country does best a millennium of
History stuffed with brilliantly Bonkers
traditions and rituals effortlessly side
by side with a celebration of modern
Britain and it's dazzling and diverse
best but of course it wasn't for
everybody
[Applause]
yeah Liverpool fans chose to boo and
Heckle the national anthem and have a
lot of offensive banners on a day where
most of the country was celebrating it
we live in a free democracy ironically
that's part of what we were celebrating
they have the right to sell those
celebrations in that manner and not have
the right to say I think they're
pathetic
and I feel exactly the same way about
the anti-monarchy protesters 64 of whom
were arrested many of them preemptively
they have a right to demonstrate against
the royal family even if theirs is a
minority view that I don't agree with
and they should be in my view an
investigation into whether police
overstep the mark by arresting them but
at the same time let's give the police
credit for this this was one of the
biggest National Security operations in
living memory and it followed two other
enormous similar operations for the
Platinum Jubilee and the Queen's funeral
and there were no events tomorrow
nothing went off that could have taken
all the headlines away to negativity or
Worse credit to them for that
but have we really got to a place where
people can't protest
in that way
I'm not so sure I feel good about that
now if any cretinous protester had
managed to bolt themselves to Street
Furniture or spook horses on the parade
or thrown things at the carriage I
believe him a charge saying that they
were idiots wrecking a spectacle but it
didn't do that and I'm not sure that
they reached the bar required to be
arrested in the way that they were
but for the most part it was a
magnificent couple of days wasn't it
Prince William I thought spoke for the
whole nation when he said this at the
concert last night
good evening your majesties good evening
Windsor
as my grandmother said when she was
crowned coronations are a declaration of
our hopes for the future
and I know she's up there fondly keeping
an eye on us and she'd be a very proud
mother
Paul
we are all so proud of you
I think we all felt the same Pride uh in
our King and then his Heir and in all
the other Royals who turned up and did
their Duty
not so much the one who turned up for a
few hours and sculpt around and snarled
and mumbled his way through an Anthem he
didn't want to sing and didn't want to
really pay any tribute to his father or
anybody else before getting back on his
plane back to California
gonna mention his name I don't like to
intrude in the private grief of somebody
who just realized he's turned into Roger
irrelevant
at a time when so much about this
country feels like it's not working and
we've had to endure so much through a
cost of living crisis a pandemic a war
raging in Europe we managed to pull off
another spectacular State event the
third in the space of the year and
they're all flawless
we've got plenty to be hopping mad about
but this weekend shows the monarchy is
not one of them I'm joined Now by talk
to the contributor Esther crackler
talked to the presenter Rosanna Lockwood
and Kevin McGuire of course from the
associated Zuma is hopping mad about the
rules because you can't stand it you
must have even even you Maguire must
have looked at those events on Saturday
and thought I'd backed the wrong horse
here no it left me completely cold it
shows you what you're gonna shows you
what you can achieve if you spend an
awful lot of public money though 250
million pounds it's a shame we don't put
that in the morning incredibly well
spent but for what that showed the world
about a country that's been ridiculed
post-brexit ridiculed in many other ways
what you're losing our power losing our
status we showed the world if there's
one thing we do better than anybody else
out there it's that kind of whatever uh
we're a Disney State a Disney country
you know with a king who gets the job
because his mother had it and she got it
because her father had it I mean what's
that sorry but I I think I would rather
that than to be in France where
literally people are setting fires to
the country in protest of their
president or in the U.S where I don't
want to even talk about a president but
they're not they're not they're not
setting fire to anything in front but
I'm sorry because they don't have a
monarchy I don't know
we have we have both of those here we
have protesters That Could set back to
things if they want to we also have a
monarchy which is a really powerful soft
power tool I understand the arguments
against hereditary uh Power Kev but it
is very important for our economy for
our outward looking face you know I'm
probably one of these globalists but I
think it's one of those things more
people go to Legoland in Windsor than go
to Windsor Castle I mean I think there's
tourists it's just massively over I
think here's my view you're entitled to
your opinion live in a democracy I
believe that Free Speech we've always
disagreed about this but we've stayed
sorry cordial yeah over the years I want
to bring in now Graham Smith CEO of
Republic she was arrested on Saturday
morning well thank you for joining me Mr
Smith I've got to say uh on balance I
don't think you should have been
arrested
well obviously yeah I mean I hadn't done
anything wrong so I think that's quite
clear
um people have not committed an offense
obviously should not be arrested and
detained for 16 hours now we spent four
months talking to the police we were
very clear in our plans right down to
the detail of uh how many placards we
had what they said the fact that we had
amplification equipment they were very
clear that they had no problem with
those plans we turned up they descended
on us in large numbers arrested US and
detained us uh unlawfully in my view so
this was a direct attack on Democracy
because democracy requires the freedom
to dissent and it basically renders this
country that no longer has the right to
protest but only has the freedom to
protest contingent on the permission of
senior officers and uh ministers I guess
I guess the concern to play Devil's
Advocate from their point of view was
that you had this massive event that was
a huge security event in many ways and
they couldn't be sure I guess that all
of your protesters in your group would
not do something stupid stupid and we've
seen a lot of very very stupid acts of
wanton vandalism from a lot of protest
groups in the last few months and maybe
they just took a view you know what
actually we're going to take a bit of a
hit on this in terms of publicity
potential
but we may stop people causing Mayhem
and Wrecking the day for everybody else
you cannot arrest
in some kind of hunch that someone else
might do something I have got a you know
I've been doing this 20 years the public
has been around for a long time we've
got an impeccable record of um being
lawful and peaceful we've been
protesting recently uh in the vicinity
of the king over you know five different
cities in the last four weeks five weeks
whatever it was and we have always
carried out peaceful protests you cannot
have a situation where the police can
simply pick people off the street in
order to stop them from protesting it is
absolutely disgraceful
um and it is a direct attack on uh on
our democracy and you know we were it is
a legitimate view held by you know
almost a third of the people now and it
has to be challenged that we have a
quarter of a billion pounds being wasted
on a vanity parade by a man who is head
of a corrupt institution who is himself
being reported to the police
um and citizens have every right to very
loudly protest against that yeah and the
police were clearly under instructions
through a stage of premeditated uh
I don't agree with anything you just
said about the king but I I absolutely
defend your right to do a peaceful
protest and I think that's what we
should have in a democracy like ours and
I know that you should have been
arrested so I appreciate you joining me
thank you very much
thank you okay I mean It's Tricky one
the police have got a very fine line I'm
told the police at these events foil all
sorts of stuff that we never hear about
uh some of it very serious so they're
very Twitchy obviously and concerned not
to allowing them to spiral but it did
seem a bit of an overreach list the
thing is but he said that the police are
not actually allowed to arrest you on a
hunch actually they are
safe than sorry and I think if they were
in a situation where there was
this or actually pose some sort of
threat or the the police said that a lot
of their criteria was someone that
looked unusual they do have a duty
primarily to protect the wider public
now obviously there will be an
investigation into it into this because
that's the kind of country we live in
which is a very good thing
um but I do think that the police were
airing on the side of caution and I
don't have a problem with it I saw you
sort of nodding along greatness what are
you feeling yeah I've lived in some um
worked as a journalist in pretty dark
and autocratic regimes and when I heard
about the police using sort of facial
recognition software and this type of
thing I understand that this is the way
that most modern democracies are going
but I think that's quite worrying
concerning we've managed to police major
events like this with these types of
protesters for decades without needing
that kind of software without needing
preemptive arresting I agree with Esther
and saying there will be inquired into
this and that's a good thing but when
people say oh well if you don't like
being a protester here try doing that in
Russia well thanks very much I don't
want this to be like Russia yeah I sort
of agree with that I want to show a
picture of Penny mordant and Her massive
sword because this is where a politician
just gets lucky where they get some
ceremonial role no one's quite sure what
it means and then they pop up in the
middle of the coronation and basically
steal the show Kevin I mean Benny Morton
is now the Pippa Middleton do you
remember the wedding show with her
derriere we now have uh penny more look
she's a royal Navy reservist was doing
press-ups to practice 51 minutes old in
that eight pound sword if Rishi sunak uh
fears is for the chop stories he'll be
worried now about Penny Morton she was
given the job of leader of the House of
Commons to get her out the way I know
does she want to be in the next movie my
favorite descriptor I've seen of her is
quite a sort of millennial one but this
but the Forbidden MILF yeah oh dear God
I don't even say that actually I think
you just did
um the other thing I thought was
interesting about it was was the
completely
well I was just airbrushing really of
Prince Harry who shuffled him with the
only Royal still talking to him Beatrice
and Eugenie and their husbands and was
then obliterated by Princess Anne's
plumage from her yeah which was
absolutely hilarious it reminded me of
the candle they put in front of Meghan
Markle if you remember at the Queen's
funeral to stop her being seen but in a
way that kind of obliteration of him
physically on camera summed up I felt
that the whole thing with him I don't
think people really care whether he
turned up or not and when he left he was
like well so what you're no longer one
of the ones we care about it's about the
king is Queen is Heir and their kids you
know she they had rehearsals so she knew
where she was sitting and he was sitting
so he'll have known it would block his
view I bet he wishes he'd taken a pair
of garden shoes to take it down but it
it was sad it looked flawed uh he looked
out of he looked uncomfortable within
like well you know what if I'm gonna put
trash in my entire family well yeah and
that's a rock up in a church full of
them yeah I'd probably feel a bit
uncomfortable too yeah
I think had one exchange with him other
than that not a single member of the
royal family even bothered to
acknowledge it it was incredible he
shouldn't have been there apart from the
two princesses do you find it at all sad
though yeah I mean I actually feel sad
for Charles actually I feel sad for
Charles and his sons behaved like such a
sport little brat
um and has gone so Rogue and I I think
Harry will regret this yeah and of
course if one of my kids behave like
this I would be utterly incensed they
certainly wouldn't be allowed to found
the events Anyway come back in a moment
uh pack we're going to talk next about
this allegation the monarchy is terribly
White the actress Ajira Ando has caused
uproar following comments that she made
about the royal family on the Buckingham
Palace balcony during the coronation
we'll debate that next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
sets out this five-point plan what has
it achieved so far enough when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apologies
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
very beloved let us Pride they're
careful who are you praying to exactly
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now
a MILF stands for mother I'd like to I'm
not going to say the next word pop the
kettle on this is the royal tea did you
keep quiet I'm trying to read the book
[Music]
it's an image that's synonymous with the
British Monarchy royal family photos on
the Buckingham Palace balcony the people
across the world are willing to camp out
in the pouring rain just to catch a
glimpse of in person this is how the
actress ajua Ando decided to describe
the moment the King Charles and queen
cumin are appeared for the first time
following their coronation flanked by
their family on the famous balcony
we've gone from the uh the uh the rich
diversity of the Abbey to have terribly
white balcony I'm very struck by that
well Netflix star who plays lady Danbury
in Bridgeton has now apologized for
upsetting people up for a comments
called the backlash on social media but
did you have a point or was her opinion
actually the thing that was terrible
well let's discuss this now with uh
Paula Roan Adrian and Tessa Dunlop so
Paula here's my problem with this
imagine for a moment we talked about the
Tongan royal family
and I said wow they're terribly
Polynesian
or terribly black
what would you have said
so I can't answer that question because
I don't know the history of the Tongan
royal family but I do know the history
of this royal family to the extent that
there are people of color in this royal
family we haven't seen for example the
descendants of Anaya her name was until
she was baptized Sarah Forbes bonetta we
don't have the descendants of for
example princess the princesses who came
from it from India why why not they're
not the kids of the senior working
Royals the only criteria for being on
the balcony is there the senior members
of the family who by the way happen to
be white when was that a crime he is not
a family of white you can shout because
you know that what I'm about to say is
going to upset you because it's right
peers Queen Victoria had a wonderful
family portrait and that family portrait
included people of color where are those
descendants why aren't they on the
balcony where is Megan where is
her 11 million dollar mansion in
California which is gained from the
proceeds of trashing the royal family
for the last three years that's where
she is I accept at the adverb of
terribly probably wasn't what I would
choose yes disappointingly all right I
would agile actually goes to my local
church and she's a seriously Good Egg
and I think she just had a sort of
instinctive reaction that wow the people
on that balcony don't look like they
represent me I would actually move away
from the idea of very distant
descendants because that would have
looked like Curious casting just for the
sake of pleasing the press and I would
have suggested we missed a trick and I
said this on your show and I've said it
elsewhere and I've been decried by all
the Royal press pack the casting of
those honorary page boys was a massive
ball drop there was no criteria to say
for instance George Prince George being
a page boy was absolutely against
protocol to have somebody in line to
succession
so my just my I just I think I have a
list here because you came out with all
this claptrap last week I can't even
read these two cards which are all the
examples of diversity of the people in
Westminster Abbey it goes on and on and
rightly on that was the most
Multicultural service this country has
ever put on the idea wasn't it was too
white it's completely ridiculous it
appears when you're talking about the
intimate royal family which you'll
remember was Rock by now on facts of
racism don't bear with people bear with
me no they're not all family members
Tommy is not a relationship Nicholas
Barkley up there they're one of the
pictures let me ask you so let me ask
you a question you got married right in
your wedding snaps how many non-white
people are
um it was a state occasion it was not a
personal wedding and the king
that's a record so you haven't answered
my question it's detracting from the
issue it is it's simplified I simply
asked how many non-white people will be
in your wedding pictures they were all
remaining because I got married to
Romanian I wanted the Tongan to be clear
they were all to be clear right you did
you didn't go around and try and find
some people who were the immediate
family and put them in your picture to
look more diverse isn't a royal family
who would have had to look very far
peers and that's the point
they're very far I'm so sorry you
mentioned Tonga earlier the king of
tongoro Queen is not also the monarch of
14 other Realms why not get 14 boys and
girls from those 14 other Realms that's
diverse because actually if you looked
at the congregation and who was invited
and looked at the procession of 7 000
people there were literally hundreds and
thousands actually people who were not
white in both of those right it just so
happens in the senior members of our
royal family they are white people which
last time I checked in this country is
not illegal you are allowed to be white
there was no suggestion and this is
ramping up unfairly what a joke was said
and remember
lots of wonderful things about the
coronation she said lots of wonderful
things about the wrong family but she
was talking about the contrast I think
it's a terribly bad view we need to put
it here and I would go as fast and call
it race-baiting it's drawing some weird
racial Dimension to a a family we know
the senior members of the family are
white we know their kids are white
what's the problem they made they made
the service and the procession more
Multicultural than anything of its kind
in the history of the world probably and
all I'm hearing is your old terribly
white it's pathetic but peers it was
about the friends they could have cast
it differently because how many friends
did you have in your wedding pictures
none but it's not a state occasion
because your family were always
Charleston Community you don't practice
when you preach no I'm not talking about
their personal Charles and Camilla
wedding we're talking about a state
occasion yeah where the page boys and
the honorary Maids of Honor could have
been recruited differently it was a real
chance he could have recruited people
who were not immediate members of your
family just go off and find random
people to take some diversity basis it's
ridiculous they could not have been more
diverse this is not about in the
planning a diversity box this is not
about taking a diversity box and I have
to actually say about King Charles he
has said himself look this is time that
we start to look inward in terms of the
role that the royal family played in
slave trade and that's important bearing
in mind don't even get me started on
that yeah Charles only just recently
finished paying compensation to slave
owners all right two thousand that's
another debate and by the way we will
have that debate because that is a
nonsense too the idea that this king who
couldn't be less racist literally
couldn't be if he dried or if I paid him
he's not gonna have to pay people or
order the payments to people from
centuries ago for stuff that isn't
happening now to anybody connected to
that is not sensical to me maybe I'm the
Mad one though maybe it was all terrible
or maybe actually I'm right thank you
right on the sense of next Tuesday
election denying former news anchor
who's blazing a trail in U.S politics
Carrie Lane's one of the most
controversial politicians in America
what does she think of our royal family
and what is she going to do about guns
in America given the latest Massacre she
joins me next in mosquitoes
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage and you're
stretching it you can say whatever
gender you are for your sex your male or
your female all right JJ plus he become
fabulous but Rishi suno sets out this
five-point plan what has it achieved so
far nothing when we say believe women
take them at their word I'm sick of
apology
thank you
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
very beloved let us Pride yeah careful
who are you praying too exactly this is
like some kind of Submarine prime
minister you're making the case here now
a MILF stands for mother I'd like to I'm
not going to say the next word
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
did you keep quiet I'm trying to read
the book
[Music]
this is talk TV
thank you
welcome back to Piers organizers or
Carrie Lake spent 22 years as a news
anchor in Arizona she's now gone to the
dark side of politics and she's a rising
star in the Republican party I'm gonna
be one it's more controversial figures
lake has been repeatedly talented as a
potential running mate for Donald Trump
acclaims she emphatically denies so it
may be true but she has hinted at a run
for the Senate well this weekend she
happened to be in London to witness
history with the coronation of King
Charles and to my delight you've agreed
to come in to my Lair and meet me face
to face lovely to meet you it's so good
to be here it's wonderful to be in
London
um we were here for a quite a bit of
history with the coronation and what did
you make of it I thought it was amazing
you know I'm all for countries
making sure that they maintain their
culture and that is such a huge part of
British culture it was wonderful it was
so you know the people of London are
tough that rain coming from the desert
of Arizona I was kind of like do we want
to stand in the rain any longer and then
I decided you know what for history it's
worth it that was like a summer's day
for us
but it was that it was amazing how do
you feel about a monarchy because I
think a lot of Americans it's
interesting obviously you drove us out
he drove King George III out um and
that's how you gained independence as a
country obviously I think that was a
terrible strategic error about the
Americas um but you did what do you feel
about the idea of a monarch it's a whole
debate raging in this country some
people believe it's kind of had his time
well I think I think the culture of
England is amazing and I'm all for 190
different countries in the world
maintaining their culture and it's a
really beautiful part of the culture of
England it's not something we're for
obviously you know 200 and roughly 40
plus years ago we threw off the shackles
of the monarchy in a in a revolution and
uh maintained and and secured our
freedom so it's not for us but I love
the culture I love going to other
countries and experiencing their culture
and it's truly remarkable what you have
here in England and you know this hasn't
happened for what 70 years yeah so I
mean that's the experience you weren't
alive I don't believe thank you
and the last coronation happened 12
years before I was born yes it's been
pretty extraordinary we've gone through
my entire life with one Monarch yes and
I think it's really amazing that you
know it all goes back to God I mean
there's just a really a vein of of God
and Christianity that kind of runs
through this as well and I thought it
was beautiful I think the Pomp and
Circumstance was beautiful again it's
not for us we we're not part of them
didn't give you a little itchy feet to
get the Royals back in did not back in
charge but I did find it wonderful I
found the people have been incredibly
polite and charming and I'm enjoying my
stay in London my sister actually lives
here so it was wonderful to visit with
her a bit as well now I want to talk to
you we've just talked about a rather to
many Americans again an acronistic part
of our culture let me talk about what we
in Britain would see is an anachronistic
part of your culture and that's guns I'm
I'm not going to start lecturing you
about guts it's your country your laws
your culture I get all that but there's
another mass shooting this week and it
comes off the back of endless mass
shootings more this year already than
any other recorded year nearly 200 I
think now
and this the sort of scale and volume of
these mass shootings seems to be getting
worse and worse what is the answer I
mean what what do you think can be done
because a million new guns are sold
every month
so the volume of guns in circulation
exponentially increases the power of
them seems to be getting uh bigger young
people seem to be suffering in
particular a lot of mental health issues
and it's turning into this awful
Groundhog Day cocktail of people
apparently going mad and committing
heinous mass shootings what do you think
the answer is okay here we are again
right right and and I think I know
you're a father and I'm a mother and
it's it's painful to see anybody any
loss of life especially you know you
never expect your children to die before
you do and in some of these shootings
we've had children dying and adults
dying and we just had a car run down a
bunch of people recently as well we're
not Banning cars or attempting to ban
cars the old regulating cars
regulating them from driving through
crowd well no but it's a very
interesting piece by Nick Kristoff in
the New York Times a few years ago
comparing what happened actually with
car regulation and comparing it to gun
regulation that cars used to kill a lot
of people in America going back a
hundred years when they first came along
and they brought in a series of
regulations from wearing seat belts to
having to have insurance to having to be
registered
someone driving a car in no basically to
a point my point was that his point was
in this very interesting column was that
there were series of regulations were
brought in and the combined effect was
that the mortality rate from car deaths
recruited we're talking about several
things I remember hang on but you raise
cars they decreased by 95 and it was a
very interesting piece which is why
don't you just regulate guns like you
did cars there are millions tens of
millions of of gun owners in America who
wouldn't dream of doing a mass shooting
they're legal their their own their guns
legally and we have a second amendment
it's it's a god-given right it's in our
constitution
the founding fathers have been
comfortable
watching this absolutely never-ending
series of mass shootings would they have
thought that was what they meant by the
Second Amendment would they have looked
to perhaps to tailor it to Modern
founding fathers would have never been
okay with what they're seeing right now
which is tyranny on our Land once again
and the second amendment was put in
place we already pushed back the tyrants
once and we didn't give up we clung to
our our guns who's the Tyranny The
Tyranny was from the monarchy and now
we're seeing an overreaching government
we're seeing a line media lying to us
taking our livelihoods away with covid
restrictions and imposing all of that on
our children and on our families and on
our education and we don't want to have
to throw back the tyrants again but they
put that in place to pres prevent us
from having to do that to protect us I
will tell you this as a mother I'm
horrified to see anybody hurt but I
don't know you haven't been on the
streets of America lately the crime is
out of control I've seen it it's not
safe to walk down these Democrat
controlled cities the murderer
I am a much better mother that I have
firearms and can protect my family and I
will protect my family you call 9-1-1
right now you can't get someone to show
up at your house Pierce and there's
crime and violence happening on our
streets and we need to protect our own
families okay but here's my question for
you I don't dispute anything you've just
said
what I would say is this something has
to be done we can agree on this right a
Fox News poll revealed that 87 of
Americans back stricter background
checks 81 agree the legal age to buy a
gun should be raised to 21. 80 agreed
that anyone who buys a gun should go for
a mental health assessment eighty
percent want police to take guns from
people consider the danger to themselves
77 what a 30-day waiting on peripheral
gun purchases okay that doesn't surprise
me because this is a would you support
those Fox News is a globalist network
pushing a globalist agenda and the
globalists want to make sure Fox News is
watched by a lot of gun owners Fox News
is a globalist network run by globalists
who want to bring down our Constitution
and take away our sector everybody who
took part in that independent poll as a
globalist
news as a globalist network does let's
just face it we all know the truth here
I don't think there's something
it's the biggest conservative Network in
the country most of it fired Tucker
Carlos
but most of it's most of its viewers I
suspect would have a pro-gun view and
you're 80 of them want all these new
measures brought in would you not agree
with any of them if you pass any of
those and make those laws they're
unconstitutional we have a constitution
you wouldn't bring in anything the
Constitution is not going anywhere I
understand that would you not bring in
any new regulations no I'm not going to
change the Second Amendment our
constitutional rights just like I don't
change the First Amendment you don't
even want background checks I don't want
to change our constitution sorry not
even background checks Pierce
what's backtracking us our second
amendment allows me to protect my family
it allows me to protect my children and
right now we're living in a very
dangerous place I'm sure the Streets of
London aren't safe either but the
streets of America you go to Portland
you go to San Francisco LA Phoenix and
you wouldn't dare walk down the street
at night even in the middle of broad
daylight and feel safe you're not safe
look at this you see what these are
do you know where they are what is it
Kinder surprise chocolate egg
so the thing about the surprise is there
are little toys inside the chocolate
eggs I've got two of them here these are
legal here that's why I'm allowed to use
them
um and they were very popular in America
and then they got banned they're illegal
in America because the CDC decided that
the toys inside because they were buried
inside the chocolate or a choking hazard
guess what the CDC also is the one who
forced masks on our children's faces
right but here's my point here's the CDC
forced masks children's faces for two
years
what the CDC says they do not control
let me ask a second amendment I missed
it do you think they should be banned
probably not I think we're overarching
with our with ours a British prime
minister told me this is a true story is
this what we're going to talk about
we're all the way here in London we want
to talk about little chocolate eggs
really actually the relevances there's a
British prime minister told me recently
that he was stopped to LAX Airport
and he had his Kinder surprise chocolate
things confiscated because they were a
danger to children and yet the number
one killer of children now in America is
guns and yet America will not regulate
guns number one they regulate chocolate
eggs the number one I simply asked why
the number one killer of young people
and I call young people 20 and younger
is fentanyl and it's pouring across our
Southern border and no one seems to give
it that's not true the number one killer
is guns no number one killer is fentanyl
of our young number one killer children
but we can disagree on that well it's a
fact it's not okay well I'm I'm worried
I'm worried as a mother about the
fentanyl killing she don't say find that
extraordinary I think it's ridiculous
akin to surprise chocolate egg is banned
in America because it may choke how out
of touch these these government agencies
like the CDC and the ATF are they're
completely out of touch they're wasting
their time on that meanwhile they're
imposing mask guidelines and and forcing
our beautiful children to have masks on
their face that's how Auto touch the CDC
is we need to take away the cdc's power
they're out of touch they're completely
out of time you want to regulate the CDC
I want to take away their power they are
an agency they have no power over us and
they're trying to impose power but just
finally on guns you wouldn't want to
implement any of these things which 80
of what I wanted to use would just
protect our Second Amendment at all
costs and you wouldn't bring in any new
regulations at all I don't see new
regulations coming in now they're
unconstitutional Pierce even if somebody
in Congress wanted to where does it say
in the Constitution we can't bring in
new regulations that shall not be
infringed our Second Amendment shall not
be that means he can't ever change it at
all listen he's already an amendment you
can try if you want but good luck
because it's the second amendment it's
enshrined in our constitution it's a
god-given right and we're not going to
give it up how do you stop the mass
shootings if you never do anything this
is how you stop them we start to address
mental illness we're not addressing that
our children are under a lot of stress
right now the world is a dangerous place
our children are feeling distressed
they're going to school they're being
psychologically abused in school with
indoctrination we're also seeing all
kinds of violence on the streets that
our children are feeling that as well
covet was difficult for our children our
young people are suffering and instead
of going after And discussing mental
illness and trying to find some answers
to that we put push big Pharma on them
and we over we have the same no no we
give them Too Many Meds we can't talk
about big Pharma just like you can't
talk about them industrial complex
you
can't talk about big Pharma right now
you can't talk about how dangerous the
vaccines are you can't talk about I
don't think the vaccines were dangerous
really no you're not seeing some of the
consequences no I think the vaccines
actually were in remarkably safe okay
let's talk about something we could
probably agree on is Joe Biden too old
to be running for president I don't
think age is a factor just as I don't
think you're all too old to be a news
anchor thank you I wasn't aware supposed
to talk but what it is more is a mental
state and a cognitive ability and I
think that we knew going into this that
cognitively he wasn't prepared and more
horrifying than his cognitive ability
is his ethics he's unethical he's taken
payouts from the CCP he's taken money
from Ukraine he's in my opinion acted in
a criminal manner against the people of
America he's supposed to be protecting
our citizens he's supposed to be
representing America and he's shown more
Allegiance toward the CCP and Ukraine
has nothing to do with his age
I my father was a very sound mind right
up until his death you could not say he
had one slip in cognitive ability but
Joe Biden cognitively is not prepared
for what he has coming at him and more
importantly I think he's he's got blood
on his hands with the way he's handled
so who should take him on the borders
from the Republicans carry who should
take him on who's got the best chance of
beating him of course you know the
answer to that what do you think it's
Donald Trump Donald J Trump but I would
argue genuinely and I've known Trump a
long time as you know I would argue he
might be the only way the Democrats win
the next episode
I've beaten him once it's hogwash really
nobody in America believes that election
was fair Joe Biden didn't win you're not
in America let me remind you I do
believe that but not never mind me so a
lot of senior Republicans okay
uh you know 81 million votes is
impossible Joe Biden didn't Garner 81
million it was a free and fair election
only one well you can say that a million
times it doesn't make it true but it's
like your election in Arizona same thing
do you really do you really want to
argue about the elections I'm happy to
only that you and Trump both refuse to
accept the result of democratic
elections and I say to you in all
sincerity I think it's a it's a it's a
vote losing premise that's fine to keep
saying I didn't lose when you did you're
better off going I lost that time next
time I'm going to win I totally
understand that I understand what you're
saying and I would just ask this when
you voted when was the last time you
voted here yes uh in the last election
okay so you voted if you've shown up and
they said you're gonna wait five hours
and 61 of the polling locations had
function non-functioning equipment you
waited five hours you showed up to vote
and the tabulator refused your ballot
and they said you know what go down the
road would you be okay with that you
have to prove them we have proven you
haven't proven that you have proven it
you haven't it's been independently
established you haven't proven I wish
you were there you say you were robbed
Trump says look Trump in the face and
I've liked Donald personally a long time
but I said to him I don't know why you
keep saying you won my 2020. nobody
wants to go back look forward offer
America a positive future
give them a reason to vote for you next
time in all about 2020. the reason
you're a rising look you're great on TV
you're very personable you're very
confident you had a little setback when
you lost why don't you just say you know
what all the greats lose all the great
Sports people talk about the power of
losing and then winning again and coming
back why not take that position rather
than saying you know what I'm just not
going to accept it I'll take my toys and
run off home and you're not going to
play with them anymore I'm sorry that's
how you see it well you know what I mean
I'm sorry you see it that way the way
that I see it and what I'm fighting for
are the people of Arizona and their vote
was taken from them we we have corrupted
to prove it Carrick may I speak you may
we have corrupt election officials we
have corrupt elections they printed the
wrong image on the ballot on Election
Day why is it not been established
independently and Maricopa County hasn't
has not rebutted that they haven't
they have not denied that and so I
encourage you to take a look at it do
you want to be senator in Arizona I'd
love you to go to my Rumble page and
take a look at our court case and see
how it played out I didn't watch the
whole thing uh okay let me ask you
you've scratched a little bit of surface
to act like you're aware of what's
happening but you're oh I just said the
light Donald Trump you've got to produce
the hard evidence or you've got to
explain what we've got you were robbed
of here that's what we've got to do is
fight for fair elections so that every
voter I don't care some of the fairest I
don't care in the world that's that's
completely you do your system is
incredible vote for 28 days in Arizona
we count for 14 days that's ripe for
frost you want to be sent into it I want
to see somebody else re-elections also
my question you want to be generally I'm
not sure what my future holds to be
honest I'm working right now on our
election case that's the center of my
would you like to be senator of Arizona
and and if for some reason we don't get
a fair outcome in our election I will
run for Senate most likely you will most
likely so you declaring now no I'm
saying most likely if we don't have a
fair outcome in our election case that I
may consider running for Senate if
Donald Trump says she wants you to be
his running mate what do you say we've
had this conversation come on I said if
the royal family invites you in and they
want you to come in I said yes you said
yes
I don't think president Trump needs a
vice president he's that powerful he's
going to have to have Peter if he runs
he's that powerful as a leader he
doesn't really need one but I do hope he
picks somebody who the media fears more
than they fear him is that you and you
know why I think he should do that
because then they'll stop trying to take
him down he's the one man fighting for
us in America you may not see it here
across the pond as they say he's the one
man who's been fighting for us and they
have been gunning for him since day one
the media's been lying about him since
day one with bogus phony
BS stories and now they're doing a bunch
of bogus phony cases against him and
that American people are on to it they
recognize he's the one man that's
standing in that Gap to protect the
people of America I don't think they're
bogus you know what I thought I thought
the Stormy Daniels indictment was a
stupid thing to go after him about I
think an ex-president paying hush money
to a porn star to cover up an affair
it's not a serious enough thing for him
to be indicted over however I do think
some of the other legal issues is in are
really serious potentially I think I
think what it does is it allows you to
say what you just said keep this in the
media we'll keep it in the media we can
talk about porn I don't have a dog in
the race we can talk about uh Aging Care
whatever we can talk about all this
stuff and it keeps it out there as a
reminder to people little little brain
worms going into people's heads to try
to turn them against Trump they're not
going to be turned against Trump because
the people of America know he's fighting
for us the people who hate Trump
the globalist he's got he's got the
right kind sounds like you're making a
little campaign address to the president
to be the running mate he's got the
right kind of enemies and I'm fighting
for him you know why I'm fighting for
him you know I'm out here speaking for
him has nothing to do with me I want
nothing I want nothing in return if you
practice your first vice president
speech I want nothing in return for me
speaking up for him other than I want my
country back I want my children to live
in an America where we have our freedoms
and our liberties intact and we're this
close to losing that and it scares the
hell out of me as a mother I'm just a
mom I'm truly a citizen who decided to
step forward and run for office and I've
been attacked by the media I sit down I
get hostile interviews and I take
everything no this is actually a little
more polite you've got the British
polite thank you which is great
um but I don't care what people call me
I care about my country and we're on the
verge of losing it and I would hope that
here in Britain if you guys are facing
the same fate that you would be standing
up for your country absolutely
absolutely I love people to stand up for
their country
thank you for coming in it's wonderful
here I'll be watching what happens with
you with great interest thank you good
to see you here's a Kinder egg
yeah
because they might it might be harmful
to children
good to see you time for a break back in
a few minutes
[Music]
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage
you can say whatever gender you are
about your sex your male or your female
all right JJ of course he become
fabulous but Rishi sooner and sets out
this five-point plan what has it
achieved so far enough when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apology
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister you're making the case
here now a MILF stands for mother I'd
like to I'm not going to say the next
word
pop the kettle on this is the royal tea
could you keep quiet I'm trying to read
a book
[Music]
well welcome back to my pack Esther
Rosanna and Kevin we'll be watching that
interview with Carrie Lee interesting
character feisty a tough cookie who's
clearly going places in America but it's
interesting this cultural divide she
finds our monarchy pretty Bonkers and
the whole thing behind it we find that
their gun violence and the lack of
willing to do much about it pretty
Bonkers let me make of it and maybe no
supporter for the monarchy but doesn't
kill people the way guns do in the U.S
uh USA I think she's a gift for the
Democrats she was wrong on on deaths you
were right a fact checked it on uh
children one to 18 the highest amount of
children killed in that age group were
by guns which is 2020 which was
absolutely certain in our ignorance and
being incorrect then I just thought it's
ridiculous big Pharma somehow uh
controlling the world I mean it's just
it's just
it seems to be this constant sense of
conspiracy everything's a conspiracy I'm
involved in it people are telling me
what to do it's for the record nobody at
Fox ever tells what to do will say on
this show
um everyone's involved in some weird
conspiracy against her against Donald
Trump I think I find that quite
exhausting that narrative it's not only
lazy as hell what a battery you know
blaming other issues rather than look at
the issue at hand but it's also deeply
deeply concerning you know for
journalists for Citizens as well I try
to respect that there are different
cultural views in America Second
Amendment gun rights I appreciate
they're different from the UK and these
matters but when you see somebody
subverting truth like that somebody who
was formerly a news anchor I think it's
terribly dangerous and terribly
concerned I mean look when you see I I
learned the hard way about the gun
debate in America they don't want to
hear British people say they want to do
with their laws right so I okay I get
that we wouldn't like it it'll be around
either but when you present a Kinder
surprise chocolate egg and you know
they're banned because they're dangerous
to kids but the biggest killer of kids
is guns and nothing gets done and we see
these endless school shootings you just
think well when does common sense kick
in to be gracious to her as far as I can
be she did talk about the mental health
issue because the the reality is there
are too many people that shouldn't have
guns crazy people and obviously that's
true but we have mental health issues
but she just skated over the issue okay
if you're going to take that angle what
exactly do you plan on doing with mental
health and tackling this issue that
doesn't infringe upon gun rights because
it still does one way or another and I
think that's the point she didn't make
she should have won Arizona I used to
live there yeah it's blue in them
she lost in Arizona the crazy and Donald
Trump lost the 2020 election and I don't
know why they keep banging on about it
or trying to sort of deny democracy it
doesn't do them any favors other
Independents are sick of them doing it
and it's not good for American democracy
everyone keeps denying results of
election fact they'll leave it there
thank you very much really appreciate it
that's it for me whatever you're up to
Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the talk that book has done
some serious damage and you're
stretching it you can say whatever
gender you are for your sex your male or
your female all right JJ plus he becomes
fabulous but Rishi tsuna he sets out
this five-point plan what has it
achieved so far nothing when we say
believe women take them at their word
I'm sick of apology
thank you
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising unmissable
and uncensored